I think with entrepreneurs I I have this
sort of test I give people to to to
colleges and there's 10 questions and
how they score it whittles down to just
a couple of people and then the final
question is are you delusional uh
because no one's sort of like a perfect
10 but a lot of it is just this sense of
urgency it's not Manana it's today I
gotta I gotta get I gotta get on this
now this is an opportunity if somebody
who's willing to sort of look at data
that has a high conviction in what they
believe but are also open enough to to
realize it's everything in life is a
hypothesis if the data shows you wrong
then you change it uh and being able to
know that you can um switch I look for
Charisma you know Charisma is a bit of a
pejorative term but charismatic people
are you know they're Visionaries people
believe in them the best line I ever
heard the hardest thing about a being a
VC is um figure out their founder is
delusional or Visionary it's a very fine
line if they're right they're Vision
there if they're wrong then they they're
probably delusional I'm willing to bet
on the delusional on for sure because if
you're delusional and you say yeah you
know I think there's something out there
and you leave Spain on a ship with some
Provisions yeah you got to be pretty
delusional to think you're going to hit
land because you might not I like the
delusional ones because if they hit land
now they're Visionary like you're saying
well I'd say I'd put that in the
Visionary Camp right delusional are the
ones that just refuse to listen they
just they're just hellbent on I am right
everyone else is wrong I don't care how
much information is coming you know
you're bias you know they just won't
listen at all oh I see yeah that's a
yeah I thought delusional as in like I
could do something that nobody's ever
done before but yeah I get your point if
you define delusional as they're
pigheaded and they will not change their
mind in the face of new data you know
that is what's wrong with American
politics today you could have new
information and people will just not
change their position in the face of new
information you look at what happened to
science in Co what happened to Media
what happened to Poli politicians the
data was so obvious I'm having an
argument right now with with a A covid
you know health expert how they
completely screwed up our our our
country based on by just simply not
looking at the data the data was so
obvious from day one why they didn't
listen to it it just became so political
it became political and then once you
give advice you can't say well you know
what now based on the statistics we have
hey we're 6 months into this we're 9
months into this you know if you're
surfing at the beach and you're outside
you're healthy and you don't have
coorbit your interactions uh and yeah if
you get a cold make sure you come to the
hospital so we can give you one of these
drugs but yeah it was pretty crazy how
nobody could think sensibly for two
years well a lot of people could think
sensibly but they were shot it down you
know if you remember the great barington
declaration you know Jay bakar of of
Stanford I mean he was great he was he
was just seen as ridicu as you know
crazy and pixie dust and it was
completely right you know we all knew
remember with Amicon that's talk about
Co yeah talk they said they said uh oh
the vaccine will stop you from getting
getting covid and we all had Omicron
like everyone we do hadic like literally
I it happened to me three weeks after I
got the vaccine I got the vaccine I went
to Sax's Christmas party his super
spreader uh spectacular as I called it
I got Omicron and uh I didn't know I had
it my wife said I heard I sneezed twice
we were skiing and she said you you got
Co and I said I don't feel anything I
went to bed I had a little bit of hot
sweats I went skiing two days later I
felt fine I tested positive for Co for
19 days I felt it was the meekest cold
for 12 hours I've had in my life
probably I'd rather have I'd rather have
C than a cold we were in we were in the
Caribbean we couldn't couldn't get back
to the country because we kept testing
POS the nurse made so much money you
just every day $300 test $300 test
trying to get back to the states are you
looking to build a SAS product you need
help on the technical side listen
developers expensive we all know this
and they're hard to find but if you use
Dev Squad they're going to help you
validate your idea and bring that
concept to Market in 3 to six months how
do they do this Dev squat is a fully
managed agency that can handle product
development end to endend this means
you're not going to just get developers
you're going to get technical product
managers designers and more all for the
price of just one US developer this
means you can focus on what you're good
at product strategy sales marketing and
they will do all the idea validation the
real user testing and they are able to
do this because there is amazing top
talent in Latin America an entire
product team for the price of just one
US developer think about how much you're
going to get done by leveraging De
squad's amazing talent in Latin America
a technical product manager that's your
main point of contact right and then
you're going to have product strategist
ux designers devops and quality
assurance alongside that product manager
making sure that your product and your
project is a success so you pay
month-to-month no long-term contracts no
lockin starts at just 40 bucks an hour
and then they can scale depending on
your needs so I want you to visit Dev
squad.com twist that's
dsq a.com twist to get more details and
to get 10% off your first
month